حدود طويله وشائكه تحكمها الجغرافيا
السياسيه والتاريخ فعلى قرابه 2200 كم
تمتد الحدود بين روسيا واوكرانيا قبل
الحرب
تغيرت الحدود الجغرافيه بفعل القتال فخسرت
اوكرانيا القرمه ومساحات من اقليم
دومباسون لكنها نجحت بتحويل حدود ضيقه مع
مقاطعه روسيه واحده الى جبهه شبه متكافئه
هذه بالكرات الروسيه
تقابلها الاوكرانيه
وخط الحدود هذا تسللت منه مجموعات تقول
انها روسيه معارضه لسياسه موسكو لتشعل بعض
النقاط في المقاطعه وتاخذ
رهائن من جنود الروس وتوجه رساله لحاكم
المقاطعه تدعوه للتفاوض
نحن على استعداد لمنحك هؤلاء الاسرى من
الجنود الروس لازاحه الفرصه للتواصل معك
شخصيا ومناقشه الوضع الحالي في المنطقه
الاهم الحديث عن مستقبلها ومستقبل روسيا
بشكل عام وعن الحرب الدمويه غير الضروريه
منذ عامين ونصف وهي الان تجري على اراضي
منطقه الخاصه بك
[موسيقى]
حدد المتحدث باسم ما يسمى فيلق المتطوعين
الروس كنيسه في بلده
الروسيه مكانا للتفاوض وقبل حاكم المقاطعه
ما يفسر اعترافا من السلطات المحليه
الروسيه بان المجموعه لديها وجود ميداني
في المقاطعه وسيطره على بعض مناطقها ايضا
ليست بالجراد وحدها التي تستهدف بقصف او
هجمات وتوغل بري كورسك المجاوره وفيونسك
ايضا
احدى عشره منطقه حدوديه تعرضت وتتعرض
للاستهداف
استهدافات تتهم موسكو كييف بالوقوف خلفها
كييف تنفي بينما تتبنى مجموعات تقول انها
مناهضه لموسكو المسؤوليه احيانا وبينما
يستمر الرئيس الروسي بالتحذير من خطوره
التلاعب بالاستقرار داخل روسيا تؤكد كييف
وجاهه مخاوف بوتين فيقول مستشار الرئاسه
ميخايلوك انها نهايه عصر بوتين